NICK BUTCHER: Hi, I'm Nick
Butcher, an engineer on the
Android Developer
Relations team.
I'm going to show you a quick
trick for your activity
animations.
So by default, when you switch
screens, Android will show an
animation between those
two screens.
A slight variation on the
standard animation is using a
grow up, grow down animation,
which helps you to retain some
context where the
users come from.
You might be familiar with this
from the Recents animation.
But you can use it
in your own app.
So here for example, I
have a grid layout.
And if I touch on one of these
tiles, this top right one,
it'll grow up from
where I touched.
And if I go from around here,
it'll grow from there.
So it helps to retain context.
I've slowed this animation down
using one of the tricks,
using one of the settings in
Developer Options called
Transition Animation
Scale just to
demonstrate this better.
If I turn that off and
go back, you'll
see it's pretty subtle.
But it really does help
remember where
the user came from.
Best of all, this is incredibly
easy for you to do
in your code.
So here we are.
I'm creating a bit map
to scale from.
So here, it's just a simple
color for my demo.
And then you just use the static
method on Activity
Options to call Make
Scale Up Animation.
And passing it the view to scale
from the bit map from
the outer scale from--
and it will return
you a bundle.
You pass this bundle to your
call to start activity.
And this will perform the
animation for you--
couldn't be easier.
One slight variation, which I've
commented out here you
can see in the code, is to
scale up just from a view
without the thumbnail options,
so if you don't have a
thumbnail to scale from.
This is slightly different.
You'll have to do a
fade animation as
well as the grow animation.
So you have a slightly
different effect.
But if you don't have a
thumbnail to scale from, you
can use this.
Thanks very much.